roll up roll up and they're all about
the latest victim of the all-powerful
unblinking thought police
I speak of Conservative MP Ben Bradley
who's found himself being likened to a
Nazi or a professor of eugenics for
comments made six years ago at the
height of the route over the benefits
cap now admittedly the way he put his
point over was clumsy but at the heart
of what he says lies a glaring
undeniable truth amid other comments
Bradley sent quits how many children you
have is a choice if you can't afford
them stop having them for Septimus are
free plates plates
he's not as the dreary predictable
ensuing witch-hunt claimed ordering
unemployed people not to have children
rather they should be able to afford
them now allowing for the fact that in
reality most of us remain blissfully
unaware if we're about to lose our jobs
surely when it comes to long-term
unemployed this is as simple as kid
stuff okay so Nick in Ghana we have a
word and the word is classy awesome and
genius translation I can't even think of
the right English translation but the
closest thing would be nonsense right
absolute nonsense I think what you're
saying is actually quite dangerous
because it is bordering on eugenics so
basically what you're saying is that
only people with money should have the
choice to have as many goods as they
want well what else are you saying you
can have as many children as you want
right but don't expect the state to pay
for no don't have children you must have
some degree of fiscal responsibility or
so I'm not stuffing rap if long-term
unemployed people will have 15 children
as long as they find a way to pay for
them fine but that's not what been badly
he doesn't say long term I allow for the
fact I don't know if I'm gonna lose my
job to my children but I love but don't
you think Nick rather what we should be
looking at the issues shouldn't be about
how many children people are having the
issue should be how do we help people
how do we help the long term
unemployed get into a separate
respectfully that's a cessation it's not
because actually we're tackling that
problem then we wouldn't even be having
your conversation yeah okay you were
shaking your head and touch nothing as
for you this is Ben Bradley as
apparently attempted to issue what I
would only call a non-apology and I
think others are calling an apology so
let's check out what it the broader
issue that I was trying to address was
that there are a lot of people
particularly places like Mansfield who
worked very hard enough to make very
difficult decisions financially about
whether they can afford to have kids and
I found that people find it frustrating
when of a small minority of people
appear to take advantage of of the
benefit system and now have the benefits
cap and we have two child limit on child
benefit and and hopefully those things
quite happened anymore but language
aside that was the broad point I was
trying to make and I still stand by that
sososo language aside I just happened to
call for the vasectomy of poor people
and I called them unemployed wasters
language aside unemployed yes unemployed
wasters if he if only he had spoken in
such measured terms to begin with we
could have had a reasonable conversation
about people taking personal and
individual responsibility which I agree
with however however he didn't say that
he called for people to be vasectomized
and called them wasters and actually I
think if you if you carefully look to
that video the word sorry wasn't
mentioned once right but he didn't he
said for septum is a free he didn't say
that people should be pointed out the
availability of it he didn't say
implication I grant you that but all
don't say no not say you say just lastly
you say you you are believing fiscal
responsibility Maji if you can't afford
to raise a family
yeah why should you have the chocolate
so I believe in fiscal responsibility
and
supports the heart he just said there in
that video is a reasonable response to
reforming the the welfare system that we
have and in his response he said that
there is a cap on to true yes I have no
problem with that
I hope I wasn't involved in the debate
that led to it but now learning that I
have no problem with apply to and if you
want more than to then work out so as I
said his language is clumsy language is
offensive the heart of what he says you
agree with in the brick but the two
words out apply to your thing is spot-on
the words that venue is were poor they
were not professional but this is a
young guy writing online five years ago
the reason that you are saying his
apologies a non-apology dollar is
because he's been bullied what do you do
know but he's been bullied into making
this statement and I'm coming on to this
in my topics that feels strongly about
this happening it's people he's being
controlled into making this statement
was something that actually he agrees
with his point is very valid and I'm one
of six children so I am all in favor of
if you want loads of kids my friend you
gonna have loads of kids but what I am
not in favor of is when you don't
exercise respects for other people
personal responsibility and you expect
actually to have all of your children
and expect other people yes to pay for
them I find that disrespectful do you
think sorry for the word unemployed
waste I think the sense of apology I
think you should have had some balls to
stand up and say what he thinks which is
I swear to my values respectful words
were wrong and the choice of words I
apologize for those words let's find out
what the word is in the trendy eateries
of West London
but surely what we decided is the
society many years ago is that we would
help fund children right it's not about
the family it's about the child is
making sure there was some money going
into that household to protect you think
all the money goes to the kids I think
in many cases yes I think I think yours
is yeah I mean you know you're doing the
show with you said I suddenly think you
come you gladly get dominated the son is
I you know scrounges actually I've no
doubt there are a few people who might
make a decision to have children because
they say that would get them more money
I don't think that's in any way and
therefore it seems to me to make the
blanket suggestion he's made everyone
everyone who's unemployed should get a
vasectomy
anybody such as wrong is if that's what
you think nicked and I don't think you
should have used his argument anywhere
near your conversation what you've done
is conflated to - you should have just
made your debate today purely about what
you think and not brought his rude and
offensive statements anywhere near your
conversational point and that's why he's
hopped into it no that's not why because
what he's saying is that he actually
thinks that what Bren is trying to say
is one thing and what I'm saying is
clearly Ben's words are not that so Nick
should say what you said what you
believe so do you agree with me with
long-term unemployed the muscle so you
can have as many children small minority
of people who appear to take advantage
of the benefit system if only he'd
spoken in those
we would have to say okay are we going
to change the whole system because of
that small minority except that in the
end you you bounce in any system where
you give handouts are the majority not
abuse and you act as if benefits is this
unlimited amount of money yes because we
have a society that has a welfare state
that's a safety net for people that
cannot for whatever reason they've got
disability is almost appalling
so I'm very proud that we've got that
welfare state what we do have and what
we shouldn't have it and this is what he
was getting to we should never have a
situation where you can choose to be on
benefits as a lifestyle choice so the
benefit society should help you in your
times of need it should never be a
lifestyle choice and that's where I have
a problem I grew with then I think what
we need is better mechanisms no no what
we need is better mechanisms to actually
help train than long time don't Smith
put it right as a hand up not a handout
what would you have done to the father
to the family with six children and both
mother and father suddenly or maybe done
certain I'm unemployed I didn't know I
did say long term unemployed because I
know it for making will there be I'm in
the home there are places in this
country where you are going to be a long
term applause yeah it's worth saying
this week we learned that employment is
at a 40-year high it is great news I
mean I couldn't even get higher maybe
Nick can go back to me a liberal